If you love to write your own copy, like
me, but you don't want to design your
sales pages, I'm going to show you a
quick trick on how to whip those up
really fast in just minutes. All right,
so check this out. So, we're on my
screen. Here's a sales page that I wrote
long time ago for my copy creator club.
All right, I'm going to take that. This
is just a plain Google Doc cuz this is
where I like to write. I like to write
in Google Docs. I'm going to take this.
[music] I'm going to go ahead and
download this as a PDF. And then I'm
going to go to a site called
lovable.dev,
okay? This is not a plug. It's just a
software that I've used before. And I'm
going to attach the file, the sales page
PDF, and [music] I'm going to prompt it.
I want you to preserve every single word
on this PDF. Don't change anything,
okay? It's really good. I want you to
design this sales page [music] into a
website for me. Make it look like a
beautiful modern sales page. [music] And
that's it. That's all I'm going to do.
And then we're going to wait. One minute
later.
>> Voilà! And here we have it, this super
beautiful sales landing page that picked
some awesome typography, add the photos
in there. I think this looks really,
really awesome. And from there, you just
go up here, hit publish, and then you
can publish it to a real domain in
lovable, and you'll have it live in
minutes. You can you can add multiple
pages, funnels, everything like that.
Hope you enjoyed this quick tutorial. If
you did, consider subscribing to the
channel so I can drop more of these for
you.